اعلن حاكم بيجروداروسيه مقتل ثلاثه مدنيين
في قصف اوكراني بطائره مسيره لمركز صحيح
قرب الحدود مع اوكرانيا من جهتها اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه
اسقطت طائرتين مسيرتين اوكرانيتين في سماء
منطقتين
الواقعتين في مقاطعه موسكو واضافت الوزاره
ان طائره مسيره ثالثه تم تعطيلها
الكترونيا فاصطدمت بمبنى مجمع موسكو سيتي
قيد الانشاء من دون ان تتسبب في وقوع
اصابات في الاثناء قالت هيئه الطيران
المدني ان مطره موسكو استانفت نشاطها بعد
تعليق الملاحه فيها لساعات بسبب الهجمه
الاوكرانيه بالمسيرات
نعم ازدهار هي كانت ثلاثه هجمات متزامنه
فجر اليوم على مدينه موسكو على
مقاطعه موسكو بثلاثه مسيرات بحسب ما اعلنت
السلطات الروسيه استهدفت احدى هذه
المسيرات مبنى النيفا تاور وهو احد
الابراج التي ترونها خلفنا هنا هذا البرج
ضمن مجمع موسكو سيتي الذي يتعرض للمره
الخامسه لهجوم بطائره مسيره منذ مايو
الماضي وهي المنطقه الاكثر
استهدافا بالمسيرات منذ شهر مايو الماضي
هذا البرج
استهدافه في تفاصيل هذا الاستهداف قالت
السلطات انها تمكنت من تعطيل احدى
المسيرات وغيرت اتجاهها وبالتالي اصطدمت
بهذا المبنى الذي يقع
قرب مبنى اخر وهو في طور البناء هنا في
مجمع موسكو سيتي حجم الانفجار طبعا طلب
بعض البنايات الصغيره السكنيه
المجاوره لمجمع موسكو سيتي كما ترون زجاج
هذه العماره السكنيه المكونه من خمسه
طوابق
تحطمت وايضا في الجهه المقابله لهذا
المبنى كانت بعض الاضرار الماديه التي
تقول السلطات العاصمه الروسيه وعمده مدينه
موسكو
على ان هذا الهجوم لم يخلف اضرارا بشريه
هذا التحدي وان كان الهجوم لم يخلف اضرار
انطونوفا
حتى وان كان الهجوم لم يخلف اضرار الا انه
تسبب في تعطيل حركه الملاحه الجويه كيف
يبدو الوضع الان في المكارات
في الحقيقه ازدهار كانت الهيئه هيئه
الطيران المدني الفيدراليه قد اوقفت حركه
الطيران او الملاحه الجويه في المطارات
المطارات العاصمه الثلاثه الكبرى وهي
لكن هذه الحركه عادت بعد نحو ساعتين فقط
والان حركه الملاحه من والى مطارات موسكو
الثلاث طبيعيه وتعمل بشكل عادي بالرغم من
ان مسيرتين سقطتا في منطقتين قريبتين من
مطار شيريميتيفا في شمال موسكو وهذا يعد
لربما تغيير في تكتيك
مسيره او مسار هذه الطائرات المسيره
باعتبار ان تلك المنطقه التي تقع الى
الشمال من موسكو لم تستهدف من قبل والحديث
عن منطقه خيمكي اضافه طبعا الى منطقه
ماجايسك التي تقع الى الغرب من موسكو وهذه
المنطقه اي كانت في الحقيقه قد استهدفت في
وقت سابق بمسيره تم اسقاطها باستخدام
الدفاعات الجويه طبعا هذه المنطقه حيث نحن
هي منطقه موسكو سيتي كما سبق وذكرت منطقه
حيويه تضم عدد من الابراج ضمن مجمع موسكو
سيتي بها عدد كبير من تمثيليات الشركات
سواء الروسيه او العالميه الكبرى اضافه
الى ممثليات عن اربعه عشر اربعه عشره
وزاره روسيا من ضمنها وزاره التطوير
الصناعي ووزاره تطوير التكنولوجي
السلطات الروسيه تضع هذه الهجمات في
الحقيقه ازدهار في اطار هجمات تحمل طابعا
لربما يستهدف خلق الهلع في صفوف المدنيين
اكثر ما هو موجه لضرب يعني اهداف
استراتيجيه او عسكريه مهمه بالنسبه لروسي
ا يمكن ان تغير مسار هذا الحرب او تؤثر
فيه بشكل من الاشكال كل الاهداف التي تم
استهدافها حتى الان في موسكو منذ مايو
الماضي هي عباره عن مراكز تجاريه مباني
سكنيه وتجمعات مدنيه ليس بها اي اهداف لا
عسكريه ولا استراتيجيه على الاقل كما تؤكد
على ذلك السلطات الروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو مراسله الجزيره امين درغامي